this video is brought to you by pedal
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here to talk about
everyone's favorite bounty hunter turned
world's greatest stepdad
the mandalorian now despite making one
of the year's best shows
its creators break a fundamental rule of
visual storytelling
show your character's freaking faces
but is this rule-bending what makes the
mandalorian so engaging in the first
place
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on star wars and masked emotions
spoilers ahead for all things star wars
and the mcu
and before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this video sponsor
pedal pedal is a credit card company
that wants to help you succeed
financially
the pedal 1 card was designed to help
you build credit many credit card
companies base your credit limit or
credit worthiness on your credit score
but if you haven't established a credit
score yet
it can be hard to get approved for the
card you need instead of a credit score
pedal uses your banking history to
create a cash score
which is essentially just a measure of
your income spending and savings
the pedal one card is partnered with web
bank member fdic which issues the card
the pedal one card has no annual fees
and as of today has variable aprs
ranging from 19.99
to 29.49 the pedal one's credit limit
starts at 500
and can range up to 5 000 which can help
keep your credit utilization low and
after all that's a
key part of building your credit score
so check out the pedal one card today
go to pedalcar.com wisecrack to find out
more
that's petzl with a t p e t a l card.com
wisecrack now back to the show now a
word on why human faces are so important
to our experience of visual storytelling
while most early cinema typically
presented the audience a view of the
world akin to a theatrical stage
some early filmmakers immediately
understood that what distinguished film
from theater was its ability to mess
with time space and perspective
enter the close-up famously employed by
early filmmaker dw griffith
close-ups were incredibly effective in
silent film which didn't have dialogue
just soundtracks full of jaunty piano
and some on-screen descriptions to help
establish exactly why a character was
angry that day
[Music]
facial expressions filled the emotional
gap epitomized by the performances in
the 1928 film
the passion of joan of arc and this
train kept rolling
into the era of talkies with close-ups
of actors faces becoming increasingly
prevalent in the 30s and 40s
just think about some of the iconic
scenes from classics like citizen kane
in casablanca where the camera lingers
on an expressive face
rather than resorting to dialogue film
theorist bayla belaz describes these
shots as
the very instant in which the general is
transformed into the particular and this
isn't just a remnant of classic cinema
recent decades have witnessed an
increased reliance on close-ups in both
film
and tv at the most pivotal moment of the
entirety of the mcu's decade long run
we are close on robert downey jr's face
right before the snap heard around the
galaxy
while he says very little his expression
conveys years of struggle and growth
all leading to a moment where this
character was able to sacrifice his life
for those he loves it's also why if i
may indulge in a tangent
nicolas cage had to fight director
robert biermann to wear sunglasses in
the wisecrack hall of fame worthy
vampire's kiss biermann complained the
glasses would shut out the audience
a fair concern when your famous actor's
face is your best cinematic asset i'm
calling the police
police albert i'm here to call it truce
man
look as usual cage prevailed gloriously
all that to say seeing the faces of
actors matters a lot in terms of how we
experience cinema philosophers like amy
copeland have even noted that we are
able to catch the emotions of a film
character through contagion
and in catching these emotions we're
sort of fusing our own emotions with
those of the character
which makes it all the more impressive
and honestly kind of confusing that a
show like the mandalorian is able to
convey so much emotion
when its protagonist is wearing a mask
for all but about 90 seconds in the
first two seasons
we feel like we know when mando is angry
or scared or sad or happy
without ever gazing upon pedro pascal's
gorgeous face
and even though we technically see the
face of the show's co-lead grogu who
i still refer to as baby yoda sue me his
face moves about as much as the
friend that thought the edible gummies
were normal gummies and spends the
entire run time of super troopers
convinced they are trapped in their body
with no way out oh and baby yoda can't
talk so
between two lead characters we have one
with a visible face
and one who communicates in a
discernible language now the whole
man in the iron mask thing isn't new to
the larger star wars universe
in the first film a new hope two of the
first characters we meet
are c-3po and r2d2 neither of whom have
the ability to bat their lashes or do
the duckface thing that dominated the
early days of selfie culture
but in both cases we are immediately
emotionally connected with these
characters with c-3po conveying a
genuine anxiety
will be destroyed for sure this is
madness
and r2d2 embodying a reckless and
adventurous spirit
[Music]
there'll be no escape for the princess
this time but for a character like darth
vader
the mask is the point the hidden face
makes him more mysterious and accessible
and daunting
like nicholas cage's iconic character
peter lowe and vampire's kiss
that goddamn contract is somewhere else
goddamn
[ __ ] files sorry i couldn't help
myself
so how is star wars consistently able to
break a fundamental principle of
compelling filmmaking
and still create an emotional connection
with its audience we might be able to
see how if we get back to the roots of
star wars by considering one of george
lucas essential influences
akira kurosawa a japanese director who
earned
international acclaim in the mid 20th
century for films like ikiru
seven samurai and his macbeth adaptation
throne of blood
his film hidden fortress was a direct
inspiration for the original star wars
film
and george lucas actually helped
kurosawa get his films financed in the
latter part of his career
and while that might be no secret to
star wars fans what is even more
interesting is one of karasawa's
influences
a form of theater that was really into
covering the faces of its
lead actors no is a style of traditional
japanese dance-based theater
in which some actors wear traditional
masks and the non-mask wearing actors
give extremely subtle and restrained
performances
it's all very on broadway since the mask
wearing actors have stagnant facial
expressions
they are unable to communicate their
moral leanings or emotional states in a
traditional fashion
this places more emphasis on the
subtleties of their physical movements
and leads the audience to find universal
themes and emotions in the actor's
minimalist performances
it's a real less is more scenario
[Music]
node's influence on kurosawa is
especially evident in throne of blood
which would go on to influence lucas's
work on the prequels specifically
where the director used aspects of no
theater to make complex emotions visible
in new ways
rather than relying on the expressive
performance as commonly seen in film
he does this through employing the
japanese aesthetic category of
jugen which describes an often
theatrically inspired emotion that
transcends singular movements or scenes
the use of mask and minimal facial
expressions and unmasked actors
help create this aesthetic as their more
minimal and controlled movements
inspire the imagination of the audience
making
them active parts of the performance
jugen isn't something that the actors
do rather it describes what the audience
feels while watching a performance
we can see this in throne of blood in a
scene where washizu has a breaking bad
moment
when he kills an assassin to cover up
his own deeds and is immediately hit
with the weight of his decision which of
course
isn't too far off from this star wars
scene in which anakin helps palpatine
kill mace windu
and seals this fate as one of the bad
guys in both cases the audience feels
the enormity of what's just happened and
knows
it won't end well obviously kurosawa
uses no categories like ugan to elicit a
response from an audience watching on a
screen
but for know itself the aim was to
create these types of responses in a
theatrical setting
the principles of no can help us better
understand why we find mando's growing
love and commitment to grogu so
compelling
without ever seeing his face we see him
go from indifferent to the child as he
drops him out to be experimented on by
some very unchill looking dudes
too curious about what the hell baby
yoda actually is
to being disappointed in him for eating
a frog woman's unfertilized eggs
to expressing a deep love and care for
him
while not masked baby yoda also conveys
emotion through minimal facial activity
and bodily movements
the artist also known as grogu might
just be one of the best examples of no
in star wars because as a specialist
puppet
he relies on muted gestures to express
any and all emotions
much like his potential dad or grandpa
or
uncle or cousin yoda we can see the
inspiration for these characters in
kurosawa's throne of blood and in
particular the spirit in the forest
and it's likely not a coincidence that
the spider's web forest
in the film looks a whole lot like
yoda's adopted home planet of dagobah
take the scene where baby yoda uses his
powers to save his new daddy from death
by
mudhorn while the tiny green puppet does
little more than scrunch its face up a
little bit
a tremendous amount of care is
communicated this is one of the first
times we realized that the little guy
loves mando
and doesn't want to watch him get
murdered and throughout the series we
see baby yoda gaze at mando in a way
that shows us the deep bond forming
between them okay
here we go there are countless examples
of emotions that are quite literally
masked in the original star wars trilogy
take the pivotal moment where our guy
darth has to choose between serving his
master palpatine or saving the life of
his son
luke it's an intense scene and you can
really feel the conflict in darth's dark
mechanical heart
even though he's masked the entire time
this gets at another important aspect of
no
theater since the masks are stagnant
unlike the kind seen in the 90s jim
carrey
classic the mask the actors don't move a
lot in moving less these actors are able
to say
more when the audience is caught up in
quiet and stillness little movements can
have a big
impact a related no concept is hana
which describes the sensations that an
actor awakes in a spectator in which an
actor's art blooms
like a flower and while blooming flowers
and genocidal sith lords
might not have a lot in common it's
incredible that after three films of
being a space fascist
were able to feel empathy for darth's
emotional growth this makes vader's
actions all the more powerful when he
throws his master into the reactor of
the death star which you know would
obviously kill someone
and make it impossible for him to come
back six films later in a pivotal role
that retroactively makes the previous
two films more or less meaningless but i
digress
you can compare the mature masked vader
in the original trilogy to the brooding
over emotive anakin in the prequel
trilogy some of the former performance
feels more emotionally intense and
expressive even though he's in a robot
suit while the latter performance full
of both
verbal and physical expressiveness feels
far less impactful
this all might help us understand why
the mandalorian is so
damn compelling while hypothetically the
most recent star wars trilogy made us
consider a global moratorium on the
production of any star wars related
content
mando and grogu's adventures through the
outer rim have restored our faith in
star wars
one might say that they've offered us a
new hope
and this is why the influence of no is
so crucial
by creating limits on facial and bodily
movements it places a heightened
emphasis on subtle forms of expression
and imbue small things with big meanings
we can think of no as adding a sort of
special flavor to film
which is why jugen an aspect of no can
be thought of as the umami of emotion
when used well
it can pull an extra layer of feeling
from the audience and have you spending
weeks wondering if mando is ever going
to see grogo again
and praying that he doesn't end up at
luke's jedi academy when ben becomes
kylo ren
no theater helps us get why the show is
so good it succeeds not because of how
much it shows but because of how little
and
rather than making the show feel hollow
and cold this restraint
and use of metal masks makes little
things so much more powerful now
some of this might be complicated by the
fact that mando eventually does take his
helmet off in the final moments of
season 2
leading us to wonder if they'll spend
parts of season 3 showing his
face in the outer rims various dive bars
but even if he does lose the mask
we would bet that the influence of no
will remain palpable whether in the
minimal movements and dialogue of key
characters
or by his growing gang of new
mandalorian friends
but what do you think wisecrack can a
japanese theater tradition help us
better appreciate the performance of
masked characters in the star wars
cinematic universe or would everyone be
better off if these guys drop
the helmets and use their eyes to
express some emotion let us know what
you think in the comments
thanks to our patrons for all your
support be sure to hit that subscribe
button like you're firing up your
mandalorian jet pack
and ring that bell like you're calling
some jedi's from the peak of force
mountain
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you